but first the fallout from the shooting
at a parkland Florida high school on
Wednesday that killed 17 people is
turning into a student-led mass movement
against guns and now President Trump is
signaling he may favor gun control
legislation students are involved in the
planning at least in four major upcoming
protests including a march on Washington
next month parkland Florida students who
survived last week's shooting are taking
to the airwaves to remote the new
campaign the tragedy at Stoneman Douglas
was not because of Stoneman Douglas it
was because people like Nick Nicholas
Cruz were able to buy these weapons
we're not going to let the 17 bullets we
just don't take us down if anything
we're going to keep running and we're
gonna lead the rest of the nation behind
us meanwhile President Trump reportedly
was moved by the site of parkland
victims during a visit to the hospital
on Friday and discussed gun control
options with friends over the weekend
this morning the White House announced
the president supports legislation to
strengthen the federal background check
system while the measure is relatively
modest and not yet opposed by the NRA it
could be a sign of more ambitious gun
control efforts to come let's discuss
this with former House Oversight
Committee Chairman jason Chaffetz and
Democratic strategist Antwon see right
Jason
congressman you were in Congress for a
long time not too long but long enough
what can you do if anything to make sure
this doesn't happen again well I wish
there was one thing we could do to make
sure that it never ever happens again
but I do like this idea of fixing the
National instance is them if you go to
the website of fix Nick's ni CS dot org
you'll see that the Shooting Sports
Foundation and others support this I
supported it when I was in Congress it's
passed out of the house I believe and it
has bipartisan support there are in the
Senate it makes sense there are some
people who can't distinguish between
right and wrong and they shouldn't be
able to acquire a gun I have a gun I
have five guns I have a concealed carry
permit I am a member of the NRA but
people who can't make these types of
decisions shouldn't be able to access a
gun and when this guy gets kicked out of
school obviously has problems the police
come to his house 30 times there's a
problem
in him accessing a gun accessing a gun
and just to give the viewers in the
audience a little more context on what
you're discussing with the fixed NICs
program currently it is not required by
federal law that states input mental
health records into the background check
system and mentally adjudicated or
committed individuals cannot at this
point buy or purchase a gun it's
prohibited there's a question about it
on the background check form when you
purchase a gun this legislation required
that states do that so there's not that
gap in the system but Antoine you have a
different take you're going after the
firearms rather than necessarily states
in putting these mental health records
why do you think we're in this position
and is blaming the NRA and accusing them
of being on the side of murderers really
forwarding this conversation well let me
tell you where I am I am I am on the
side of common sense gun reform measures
being implementing this country I have
zero confidence in Washington DC
dysfunctional city to get this done I
think we have to lean heavily on local
legislative bodies and even local
governments like here in Columbia South
Carolina where I'm from where the mayor
and the City Council and in a very
unified way banned the selling of bum
stocks but here's what I think keep in
mind it was this president who signed an
executive order to reverse a decision
that implemented by the Obama
administration to take the take guns out
of the hands of those who have mental
issues I'm really glad you brought that
up because it's actually not true what
President Trump did was rescind an
executive order by President Obama that
said that Social Security recipients and
veterans who wanted someone to help them
with their finances were then deemed
mentally unfit and therefore unable to
pass a background check and their second
Amendment rights were taken away but due
process so to say that he took something
back that now enables mentally ill
people to get a gun dress isn't true
Jason I want to go back to I want to go
back to user we heard a whole lot about
new gun control measures and people
saying that this is an issue of making
sure we take certain kinds of firearms
off of the streets there's also the
other side of the argument that we
haven't heard as much about there are
students in that school who don't like
being sitting ducks there are a number
of teachers who are remembered
the NRA there are a number of NRA
members who have children who go to
these schools who believe that they are
soft targets and that things need to be
changed what do you say about school
districts around the country who have
decided to allow teachers to be armed
inside of their classrooms no look
you've got some teachers that can't
negotiate a Monson burner so it's not
for everybody but I think these are soft
targets you've got to be able to make
sure that individuals can't get into
that into that school in the first place
one of the reports we heard out of
Florida is they had some bulletproof
glass or some hardened glass so he
couldn't actually shoot out the window
and shoot it that students that were
fleeing but you're gonna have to have a
resource officer maybe it's a police
officer who's on duty or off duty who
knows how to wield a gun and I do
believe that certain teachers in certain
places should and can be equipped they
do it in Colorado they do it in other
places and I think it's a good idea for
a lot of places and by the way Baltimore
Chicago and Washington DC have some
rules and laws yeah well that's true and
they have some of the biggest problems
with guns Anton you want to respond to
that is that not is that in a relevant
point is that not a relevant point to
bring up and the fact that Chicago's had
hundreds of murders in 2017 and yet it's
on the headlines every day if it's the
go-to Republican pivot talking what is
the go-to Republican tell you a reason
let me tell you a reasonable people want
they want to not have ak-47s on the
street a 19 year old who can't rent a
car or buy wine should never be able to
purchase an ak-47 reasonable people want
to close the Charleston loophole so so
for instance my friend clementa pickney
who was killed in a church here in
Charleston South Carolina so that will
not happen again
reasonable people want to ban bum socks
the reasonable things that people want
to do and stand-up the traditional pivot
to talk about Baltimore and Chicago okay
you talk about being reasonable is it
unreasonable to think that places like
Chicago and Baltimore that have all the
gun control legislation you could
possibly ask for would not be the
the examples that we should follow
considering their murder rates sure but
here's what I'll tell you I'm not saying
gun control is the all out be our final
answer but I think it will be part of
the solution to the problem in this
country to prevent another Charleston to
prevent another Newtown to prevent
another partly a Florida all right we
seem that has it worked but Jason last
word - you know I look I would get rid
of bump stocks as well but there is a
lot of Education that needs to go on and
but I look I'm a I own guns I have a
constitutional right to own guns but
there's nothing a way to find people who
are mentally unfit to be able to they
shouldn't be able to purchase them and
if they run into trouble then they
should be they should take those guns
away this kid should have never had it
and they got to tie all those loops
together right we do 98k forty-sevens on
the street right I think that that's an
overstatement of the situation but thank
you to you both for coming on the show
thank you